Alright.
>> So it's very cool that we have all this social functionality. I like that.
>> Yep.
>> what should we do next?
>> So, similar to how we have this, You Can Make a Post,
or Post a File, or Create a New Task. We can create our
own actions that we can surface in Chatter, to make our lives easier
to do, you know, a bunch of things that we're doing all the time.
>> Okay.
>> Using Chatter. And so, the cool thing about doing that is when we do these
actions, it actually posts to Chatter at the
same time. So we can track when these actions
are happening.
>> Sounds good.
>> So, what's something that we might want to do, related to
stage? Something that might happen pretty often in a music festival.
>> I mean, we might want to change the bookings of the bands, or
something like that. Update, so one of our set times. Can we do that?
>> So, updating set times, no. Creating set times, yes.
>> Okay. Why, what's the difference?
>> So, updating set time would be something
that we would do from the set time record.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But we can create set times.
>> Right.
>> From the stage itself.
>> Okay.